[Music]
when a person gives himself heirs
because he can understand and interpret
the books of chrysippus say to yourself
if chrysippus had not written obscurely
this man would have nothing about which
to give himself heirs
but what is it i want to learn nature
and to follow her i seek therefore
someone to interpret her and having
heard that chrysippus does so i go to
him
but i do not understand what he has
written i seek therefore the person who
interprets chrysippus and down to this
point there is nothing to justify pride
but when i find the interpreter what
remains is to put his precepts into
practice this is the only thing to be
proud about
if however i admire the mere act of
interpretation what have i done but
turned into a grammarian instead of a
philosopher the only difference indeed
is that i interpret crucifix instead of
homer far from being proud therefore
when someone says to me read me
chrysippus i blush the rather when i am
unable to show him such deeds as match
and harmonize with his words
epictetus was a teacher of stoic
philosophy and so he he moved in circles
in which people did talk a lot about
stoic philosophy
and he also probably had a lot of
students who came to him who had done
some previous reading
so you notice that he talks here about
chrysippus chrysippus was sometimes
called the second founder of the stoic
school in part because he wrote so much
and he also wrote a lot in response to
critics of the stoic school
sometimes attacking them sometimes
defending the stoic principles and so to
read chrysippus was in in many respects
for ancient people to study stoicism and
so epictetus um
wants to counsel us against what we can
call the difference but not between book
smarts and street smarts the way people
uh like to take like to talk but between
sort of an academic
theoretical treatment of stoicism and
then actually making it part of your
life actually practicing it
so he says when a person gives himself
heirs because he can understand and
interpret the books of chrysippus
say to yourself well that's because
chrysippus wrote obscurely and so it's
difficult to understand him
similarly you know we have a kind of
distance with with respect to epictetus
he wrote in in koine greek and it's
trans translated often by these kind of
oxfordy you know uh types and so it may
be a little bit difficult
i shouldn't myself for example put on
ears in providing you this commentary
because um all i'm doing is is sort of
bridging a gap right if it was super
easy to read epictetus and to understand
everything that he was saying no need
for commentary right so he goes on and
he says um
what is it that i want i want to learn
nature and to follow her so i seek there
for someone to interpret nature
and having heard chrysippus does so i go
to him this is why we read philosophers
this is why we study with with
philosophy teachers because we think
well they've got something that i want
it's not necessarily the the end product
it's something that will get me there
and so i go and i read chrysippus
because i've heard this chrysippus guy
knows a lot of stuff he can explain
things really well he's you know he's
going to help me out right and so
i read them and then i say oh i
i don't understand what's going on here
i can't understand what has been written
so then i go and find as he says
somebody who can interpret chrysippus
and then he says down to this point
there is nothing to justify
pride there is nothing
to
justify making a big deal out of oneself
and then he says when i find the
interpreter the interpreter what remains
is to put his pur his precepts into
practice
this is the only thing to be proud about
if you want to be proud be proud about
the fact not that you've studied the
philosophy not that you've got a diploma
in it not that you
have uh you know whatever marks or
distinctions you want be proud about the
fact that you can actually apply it
in a real way
not just in a theoretical way not just
in a maybe down the line i'll do this
sort of thing sort of way but in a real
way
so he goes on and he says
if however i admire the mere active
interpretation
what have i done i've turned into a mere
grammarian a person who studies not just
grammar but literature that's what
grammarian meant back then a person who
studied it and taught it perhaps rather
than being a philosopher
so he says the only difference is that i
interpret crispus instead of homer far
from being proud therefore when someone
says to me read me chris i blush when i
when i'm unable to show him such deeds
is match and harmonize with his words
that is really a
interesting thing to say at the end
we talk a lot about you know
different figures or or different
authors or even you know filmmakers or
things like that
how cool they are about you know what
characters they develop and show us
the real test for all this is whether we
can't incorporate that into our own
lives
otherwise
it's just
sort of an academic exercise
and if you want to do academic exercises
that's fine
stoicism is about more than that
whatever principles are set before you
stand fast by these like laws feeling
that it would be impiety for you to
transgress them
but pay no attention to what somebody
says about you for this is at length not
under your control
in this very short chapter number 50
epictetus tells us two things that are
not really connected with each other
one of which is very rich in
implications and the other of which is
is a repetition of things that we've
heard a number of times so i'm going to
start with the second he says pay no
attention to what somebody says about
you
for this is at length not under your
control and this is a reminder that we
don't have to be concerned with how
other people view us
because that is something that we don't
control it's largely a product
of their own filters and their own you
know aims and desires and you know how
their desires and aversions flow out
into the world we should think of other
people as essentially being in the same
condition as ourselves except not having
had the message that that stoicism is
able to provide them with and is usually
thinking that they're doing all right
that they've got things figured out even
though they're usually quite a a mess
right so we don't have to worry about
what they think about us
now the thing that's more
uh rich in implications like i said here
is this very short passage which is what
whatever principles are set before you
stand fast by these like laws the greek
term is nomos
feeling that it would be impiety for you
to transgress them that it would be it
would be not only wrong in a moral sense
but that there would be something like
you know the bottom dropping out of the
universe so you know when somebody uh
goes against what they consider to be
holy uh that which provides
meaning running throughout the entire
existence of the person when you go
against that that's more than just going
against a social opinion or even against
you know what you know to be right or
wrong unless you've got a very very
highly developed sense of right or wrong
and now notice that he talks in terms of
laws
now why is that important
in part because
we should look at these these principles
that are given to us the ways that we
ought to behave that have been discussed
throughout the rest of this this work as
being something like rules that we don't
get to play
loose with we don't we don't get to
interpret and say well uh it doesn't
apply to me in this case because this is
a this is a special exception and you
know so what would be an example of that
if it's bad for you
to lose your temper at somebody
at all as is what the stoics think then
you don't get to say oh yeah but they
said something mean to me or they let me
down or they cut me off in traffic it's
bad for you and you shouldn't do it and
so you know what is what does the rest
of the law say okay acknowledge that you
screwed up and then don't just say oh
i'm gonna acknowledge it and then move
on
do what you need to do to fix things fix
things with the other person if that's
what needs to happen and also fix things
within yourself so that you can
quit making that same mistake
if you
allow yourself to be upset because some
person who promised you a job doesn't
come through with the job you know
these are things that happen all the
time
realize that
this is one of these cases where you
need to to apply the distinction between
what's in your power what's not in your
power
don't say well on this occasion i get to
go out and commiserate with my friends
and complain about how unfair the
process is
because it really was more unfair this
time
if you're going to treat stoicism as
something that you can kind of pick and
choose
it's not going to be as successful for
you now epictetus doesn't say that you
know you can't try that go ahead and try
it out see how that works and see if you
actually make any progress epictetus is
saying if you do want to make progress
you need to
treat the principles that you've got to
work with as if they are laws that apply
all the way across the board
and then follow them
how long will you still wait to think
yourself worthy of the best things and
nothing to transgress against the
distinction set up by the reason
you have received the philosophical
principles which you ought to accept and
you have accepted them
what sort of teacher then do you still
wait for that you should put off
reforming yourself until he arrives
you're no longer a lad but already a
full-grown man
if you are now neglectful and easygoing
and always making one delay after
another and fixing first one day then
another after which you will pay
attention to yourself then without
realizing it you will make no progress
but living and dying will continue to be
a layman throughout
make up your mind therefore before it is
too late that the fitting thing for you
to do is to live as a mature man who is
making progress and let everything which
seems to you to be best be for you a law
that must not be transgressed
and if you meet anything that is
laborious or sweet or held in high
repute or in no repute remember that now
is the contest and here before you are
the olympic games and that it is
impossible to delay any longer and that
it depends on a single day in a single
action whether progress is lost or saved
this is the way socrates became what he
was by paying attention to nothing but
his reason in everything that he
encountered and even if you are not yet
a socrates still you ought to live as
one who wishes to be a socrates
even though it was written over two
millennia ago this
advice that we're getting in chapter 51
is always timely and why is that the
case well whenever we read it it always
does apply to us and it's about time
and about you know the progress of our
lives and about the fact that we've
already wasted enough time
frittering it away
not doing what we ought to do
and now is the time to decide or we can
put it off some more and maybe see what
happens that's our choice we we do have
a free faculty of choice but epictetus
says here that no it is time to make a
decision and notice towards the end how
he frames this he he talks about the
olympic games and this is sort of like
the pinnacle of athletic success so this
is talking to each of us as if we are
going into the olympic games and and we
are the olympic games of life whether we
become the kinds of people that we were
originally intended to be
or whether we
continue on with the kinds of people
that we've wound up being and we've made
ourselves
that is that is a the most important
thing in the world to epictetus so he
says
remember now is the contest
here before you are the olympic games
it is impossible to delay any longer it
depends on a single day and a single
action whether progress is lost or saved
and we'll come back to that in in a
little bit but i wanted to stress this
this this metaphor of the olympic games
because it shows us that he he considers
this to be the most important thing your
business success your love life your
circle of friends
how your body looks those are minor
compared to whether you get yourself
straight
about who you are
what kind of thing you are and what you
have the potential to be and then do it
it doesn't do any good to know all this
and then not actually practice it any
more than it would for an olympic
athlete to go and you know stand there
with all the other swimmers and then the
gun goes off and they just stand there
thinking about i really like swimming
swimming is so cool
you've got to jump in the water and move
right so let's let's start where he
starts
how long
will you still wait to think yourself
worthy of the best things
that's a really interesting question
we have a lot of self-help people who
push and also in you know other other
areas as well they push this oh you have
to think of yourself as as worthy of
goodness and then the universe will give
it to you
they often have a mistaken conception of
what goodness is
and about being worthy is
epictetus thinks
that we're worthy
of living in accordance with nature
having our our for our
faculty of choice
uh in accordance with nature making
ourselves into the kinds of people that
we have the potential to be without
conflicts within ourselves
dealing all right with the conflicts
that arise in the outside world happy
unfettered
free
that is a possibility for us
that is better than anything else that
we could be provided with that's better
than winning the lottery that's better
than the
you know person that you find who you're
totally attracted to that's better than
statues being erected to you that's
better than
being invited to give a set of
prestigious lectures that's better than
all of these sorts of things according
to epictetus
not that those aren't you know nice
things
but they'll certainly be put in in
fuller perspective if you're actually
happy in your life so he says how long
are you going to wait
how long are you going to wait to not
transgress against distinctions set up
by reason
this is another key theme in this
passage
what is going to guide you towards that
it's your faculty of reason of
rationality what is distinctively human
in you
what you have and what you need to
develop
you know it's not as if your faculty of
reason is perfect it's not like you know
plug-in software or hardware that you
just pop into your motherboard you need
to work on it you need to develop it
that's why education is so vitally
important
so he got he goes on and he says look
you've received the philosophical
principles which you ought to accept
you've been studying stoicism
you've got it in your hand
now um you've accepted them
at least in a certain sense you have you
have taken them in
what sort of teacher then do you wait
for who are you waiting to solve your
problems who are you waiting to give you
the advice about how to proceed
why are you waiting around for somebody
else
to
give you the guidance you have the
resources you need
so he goes on and he says what sort of
teacher do you wait for that you should
put off reforming yourself until he
arrives
now it that's not to say it's not
helpful to have a teacher or interpreter
my hope in producing these videos is
that you know my years of studying
epictetus help you as you study
epictetus and try to apply this in your
life not to say that that any of that
doesn't help right
but this is the great thing about
stoicism you can do it whether you're on
a desert island by yourself
or in the middle of a metropolis as a
lonely person who doesn't know anybody
who just got plunked down there because
i don't know your flight got canceled or
something like that
right
you don't have to wait for somebody else
to come along and solve your problems
for you you've been given what you need
so he says all right you're no longer a
child
but already a full-grown person
and at the time that that i think most
of us read this there may be some people
who are in fact uh you know adolescents
who are watching this and maybe his
advice doesn't fully apply
to you you know we know for example that
impulse control is something that
continues to develop as we get older um
you know up till 25 now we've we've
realized although science may tell us
something different in years down the
line and so you know this may not apply
to everybody although certainly one can
begin to practice stoic philosophy as a
young person but for those of us who are
no
longer children
and adolescents
what's our excuse
why aren't we putting it into practice
what is it that we're waiting for
he says
if you're now neglectful and easy going
and always making one delay after
another and fixing first one day then
another
after which you'll pay attention to
yourself
what's going to happen
now think about this people do this sort
of stuff
you know they create an intention oh
it's new year's i am gonna finally get
my life in order i am gonna start like
getting up every day and meditating and
you know doing some visualization
exercises and reading my way through the
end caribbean or the discourses or
seneca's letters or whatever and i'm
going to really put it into practice
people make all sorts of plans like this
oftentimes i think that the plans uh
substitute for the actual doing because
it's a lot easier to sit there and drop
all sorts of plans and schemas than to
do the hard work of looking at yourself
and saying i don't like what i'm seeing
i need to fix this this is disgusting or
this is revolting uh
maybe my aversion needs to be turned
towards the fact that i do this and i
have these you know reactions that i
don't want to have
right but people sit there and they make
plans and they talk and talk and talk
and you know they don't actually do
anything um it's not stoicism too that
that's a
you know peculiar in this respect you
can think about saint augustine in his
confessions he talks about a period of
years and years and years where he's
he's you know basically ready to make
the plunge into living a fully christian
life and he says you know this famous
prayer god give me chastity but not yet
not yet because i still want to enjoy
myself a bit there's time for that later
and then at a certain point you're like
this is this is nuts i i shouldn't be
behaving this way if i really think that
this is the best way i should be going
full steam towards it i should be as
people say all in
so he says what's going to be the the
cost if you are neglectful in this way
you make one delay after another and you
just make a bunch of plans and talk talk
talk talk talk
well
without realizing it you will make no
progress
but living and dying will continue to be
a lay man throughout a person who is not
on the philosophical path a dilettante
you will not make any progress
as a matter of fact the only progress
you'll make is probably in being better
at lying to yourself about the progress
that you're making and putting out a
better face of a dilettante to other
people so they think that you're hot
stuff and that you're actually into
stoicism
but if you're not doing it there's no
benefit to you
and the longer that you keep on delaying
he doesn't mention this here but delay
itself can turn into a habit which then
you have to break as well that becomes
even tougher
so he says look
now is the time
make up your mind before it is too late
that the fitting thing for you to do the
right thing for you to do the
appropriate thing is to live as a mature
person who is making progress
make a choice to to actually grow up as
we say
and and behave like a mature person take
responsibility for your own feelings
take responsibility for your choices
past and present
take responsibility for your thoughts
for what it is that you filter
situations through for the stories that
you've told yourself take responsibility
for all of that
and then he says let everything which
seems to you to be best for you
be a law which must not be transgressed
here's that conception of law again if
you think that you should do
some sort of
action like you know you decide that
meditating every morning is what you
need to do then do it
make it a law for yourself quit talking
about it quit you know uh making plans
to do it quit reading benefits about it
in you know articles and stuff like that
do it
and if you stop doing it then take
yourself to task say i broke the law
that doesn't mean you need to be
punished or anything but get yourself
back on track quit making exceptions
so he goes on and he says
if you meet anything that is laborious
or sweet or held in high repute or in no
repute
remember now is the contest if you meet
the things that we we encounter as
challenges you know laborious things
that are going to require a lot of work
on our part
that we're type we you know we tend to
be averse to we put that off
sweet
temptations right that can draw us in
that can get us to do things that we
shouldn't do
we have to stand up against that
held in high repute held in low repute
that shouldn't matter to us
now is the time
that's why i said this is very very
timely advice because anytime you read
it you can apply this
whether it's you know two millennia ago
whether it was you know yesterday when
you first read it or you know and then
ignored it whether it's today when
you're watching this video and saying oh
i should go back to that re-read that
passage
it applies to us at at every time now is
the contest
so he goes on and he says
um
it's impossible to delay any longer it
depends on a single day in a single
action whether progress is lost or saved
again this is why we want to make these
these precepts into laws for ourselves
because
we as soon as we start to backslide as
soon as we start to give in we start
losing the progress that we've made
and we start to fall back into the
natural tendencies
the old habits of thinking which are
actually tendencies against nature
against what human nature ought to be
but i say natural in a different sense
here
these tendencies to to justify ourselves
to tell us that it's okay for us on this
one occasion that you know
we we can fix it tomorrow or that we
weren't really doing it we were just
trying to do this instead all these
things are excuses that we give
if we want to really follow along the
path of progress we can't cut ourselves
any any slack in this respect
you know when we can cut ourselves slack
is after we've screwed up and then we
don't have to tear ourselves down but we
giving ourselves slack doesn't mean we
don't get right back on the treadmill
and start exercising again
we have to
look at things honestly we have to be
true to ourselves and true to reason
in our self-examination
so he goes on and he says this is the
way socrates behaved socrates became
what he was and socrates is a great hero
to the stoics
by paying attention to nothing but his
reason
his
rationality in everything that he
encountered
socrates
got himself killed
by practicing philosophy
and why did he practice philosophy
because that seemed more rational to him
to do
than to do the opposite
and he tried to reason with the judges
he didn't convince them
his friend actually
bought off the jailers and said hey we
can transfer you to another city and you
can do philosophy there and you don't
have to die what did he say to credo
let's think about this let's reflect on
this let's reason about it
and his reasoning took him to the end of
no it's better to obey the laws and to
stay here and be executed
socrates made such an impression on
people because he did in fact use his
rationality he followed it
he didn't you know
make exceptions and say well my feelings
are saying this so i'm going to ignore
what reason tells me
that would lead them to question his
feelings which we ought to do
our emotions are not always the
not not even often the best judges or
guides or interpreters of the situations
that we're in so he says even if you're
not yet a socrates still you want to
live as one who wishes to be a socrates
if you want to be a stoic that's what it
what it means to be a stoic to want to
live like a socrates to want to live
like a hero to want to live as the
olympic victor of life and the good news
is this is in all of our power our
bodies i'm not up to competing in the
olympics i'm not even up to competing in
you know professional or or even amateur
sports of any sort right
but
we can do this
with our our choice our faculty of
choice our rationality
any one of us
can live a fully human life
it's up to us to decide to do that and
the time to choose is when you become
aware of that
not down the line in some distant future
that may never happen because you can
get hit by the bus tomorrow you could
get sick tomorrow
do you want to reach the end of your
life and say
oh yeah i always had the intention of
trying to live this way never really did
it
kind of sad about that
or do you want to be able to look back
over a time back to the time where you
finally said yes i need to make a
decision and stick with it
[Music]
you